Esta es la pregunta que todos nos estamos
hacienda estos días: ¿Qué pasaría si Corea
del Norte y Corea del Sur se reunificaran
y se convirtieran en un único país?
Por supuesto, no es algo que tenga que ocurrir
necesariamente.
Al menos a corto plazo.
Pero está claro que es una posibilidad…
que podría darse mucho antes de lo que pensamos.
Hace solamente un año, nadie habría dicho
que, en la primavera de 2018, Kim Jong-un
fuera a terminar dándose la mano con el presidente
Surcoreano, Moon Jae-in.
Así que ¿Qué pasaría si las dos Coreas
se reunificaran?
Lo cierto es que ya hay un precedente histórico.
Sí, amigos de VIsualPolitik, estoy hablando
de la Reunificación ALEMANA.
Todos lo sabemos; Alemania estaba dividida
en dos bloques: Alemania Oriental por un lado,
con un régimen socialista, y Alemania Occidental
por el otro, con un sistema capitalista.
Con la caída del muro de Berlín, la parte
Oeste absorbió la parte del Este.
Desde entonces, el gobierno se ha gastado
auténticas fortunas para que los Alemanes
orientales puedan tener una calidad de vida
similar a la de los Alemanes occidentales.
Casi todos los expertos aseguran que esto
es un caso de éxito.
Muchos dicen que debería ser el modelo a
seguir para una posible integración de las
dos Coreas.
Pensadlo bien: en ambos casos tenemos una
parte capitalista y una socialista.
En ambos casos, una parte es mucho más rica
que la otra.
En ambos casos, hay un idioma y una cultura
común.
Pero la pregunta es… ¿De verdad fue tan
fantástica la reunificación alemana?
¿O sólo en teoría?
Podemos decir que los alemanes orientales
están al mismo nivel que sus vecinos occidentales?
Mmmmm la respuesta es NO.
Incluso en el fútbol se pueden ver todavía
las diferencias.
Para que os hagáis una idea, a día de hoy,
todavía no hay ningún equipo de Alemania
del Este jugando en la BUNDESLIGA.
Los equipos occidentales dominan el fútbol,
que resulta que es el deporte nacional alemán.
Y lo mismo pasa en la economía, aunque de
eso vamos a hablar más tarde.
Pero donde las diferencias dan más miedo
es… ¡En la política!
Por ejemplo, en las últimas elecciones, el
partido de extrema derecha ALTERNATIVA POR
ALEMANIA entró en el parlamento como la tercera
fuerza política ¿Y a que no adivináis dónde
consiguieron casi todos los votos?
¡Exacto!
En la antigua Alemania del Este.
Para que os hagáis una idea, esta es la primera
vez desde 1961 en la que un partido de extrema
derecha tiene una presencia tan grande en
el parlamento alemán.
Y eso, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
es para echarse a temblar.
¿La venganza del Este?
La furia en la Antigua República Democrática
Alemana ayudó a Alternativa por Alemania.
Así que la pregunta que nos deberíamos hacer
es…
¿Ha terminado ya el proceso de la reunificación alemana?
¿Qué podemos aprender de este caso que se
pueda implementar en el de Corea del Norte
y Corea del Sur?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes… antes, voy a hacer un pequeño paréntesis.
Sí, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik…
nos habéis mandado más de 100.000 mensajes
pidiéndonos que hablemos de Cataluña.
Y tras muchos meses de trabajo, este jueves
11 de mayo hablaremos de este tema.
Vamos a contar con el mayor experto de autodeterminación del mundo.
Así que estad atentos a nuestras actualizaciones
porque tantos meses de espera van a merecer
la pena.
Y ahora sí ¡Vamos a ver un poco de historia!
EL GANADOR SE QUEDA CON TODO
Tras la II Guerra Mundial, los aliados dividieron
Alemania en 4 zonas de ocupación militar.
Los Británicos se quedaron con el Noroeste,
Francia con el Suroeste, Estados Unidos con
el Sur y la Unión Soviética con el Este.
Podríamos hablar durante horas sobre todos
los detalles de esta ocupación… pero entonces
estarías horas mirandome mover las manos
y os daría un ataque epiléptico.
Así que, en resumen, a partir de 1949, Alemania
queda dividida en dos países: el Oeste capitalista,
con capital en Bonn, que se llamaba la República
Federal Alemana.
El Este, socialista, con capital en Berlín
Este, que se llamaba la República Democrática
Alemana.
Poco a poco, Berlín Este se convirtió en
una gran metrópoli capitalista, como podría
ser cualquier ciudad estadounidense.
Mientras tanto, Berlín Este se convirtió
en una copia en miniatura de Moscú.
La constitución de Alemania Oriental decía
que sus ciudadanos tenían toda clase de derechos,
incluido el derecho a huelga.
Pero la realidad era muy distinta.
Todas las decisiones se tomaban desde el llamado
POLITBURÓ, que era algo así como el comité
directivo del Partido Socialista.
Y prácticamente el único medio de comunicación
era un periódico financiado por el partido
único.
Aquí podéis un ejemplo de su objetividad
y calidad informativa…
NUEVA ALEMANIA: el órgano central del Partido
Socialista Unido.
Hoy celebramos 100 años de la Publicación
del Manifiesto Comunista.
Como os podéis imaginar, la economía de
la Alemania Oriental estaba totalmente centralizada
y, prácticamente todas las fábricas y empresas
eran propiedad del Estado.
Para que os hagáis una idea, el Gobierno
fijaba los precios de todos los bienes y servicios.
Es decir, que cada año, el Gobierno publicaba
una lista con todos los precios que tenían
que tener las cosas.
Ejemplo: una barra de pan?
5 marcos.
¿Un Walkman de importación japonesa?
1000 marcos.
Y así con todo.
En muchos casos, aunque tuviérais el dinero
para comprar las cosas, teníais que poneros
en lista de espera.
Ahí está el ejemplo de los coches… los
famosos TRABANT alemanes.
Si queríais comprar uno, teníais que esperar
hasta 10 años desde que lo pedíais hasta
que os lo entregaban.
Como os podéis imaginar, este tipo de políticas
generaban escasez, desempleo y… en fin,
que miles de alemanes orientales quisieran
escapar a la parte occidental.
¿Y qué creéis que hizo el Gobierno del
Este para evitarlo?
Pues… ¡Construir un muro!
¡El famoso muro de Berlín!
Por supuesto que para justificar esta decisión,
el Partido Socialista decía que querían
evitar “infiltraciones fascistas” en su
país.
Pero la realidad era exactamente lo contrario.
Como os podéis imaginar, las relaciones entre
las dos Alemanias no eran precisamente amistosas.
Alemania Occidental no reconocía a la parte
Este y entendían que ellos eran los auténticos
representantes de toda Alemania.
Y lo mismo pasaba al revés.
¿Os recuerda a algo?
Sí, es más o menos la misma relación que
tenían Corea del Norte y Corea del Sur…
pero sin bombas atómicas.
Y al igual que ha ocurrido con las dos Coreas,
las dos Alemanias normalizaron sus relaciones
en los años 70.
Sin embargo, el auténtico punto de inflexión
llegó en el año 1989.
En aquel momento, la República Democrática
Alemana celebraba su 40 aniversario.
Nadie se imaginaría que también sería el
último.
Pero eso es lo que tiene la historia, que
es impredecible.
Y los cambios se dieron a velocidad de crucero.
Tan sólo 10 meses después de la caída del
Muro de Berlín, las dos Alemanias se unían
en lo que hoy conocemos como Alemania.
“La nueva Alemania está aquí” dijo el
Secretario de Estado James A.
Baker dijo que “tras 45 años, finalmente
tenemos la aritmética correcta y tenemos
una Alemania en una Europa unida y libre”
Pero, seamos honestos… en realidad esto
no fue una unión de dos países distintos
sino una absorción.
Básicamente, el 3 de Octubre de 1989, Alemania
del Este desapareció como un país independiente
y pasó a forma parte de lo que era Alemania
del Oeste.
Desde luego, era una buena idea.
Pero también tenía sus puntos flacos.
¡AL FIN JUNTOS!
Por fin las dos Alemanias se habían reunificado.
Pero no todo era tan bonito.
Veréis, Alemania occidental ya era un país
rico, con empresas productivas y de tecnología
puntera.
Alemania oriental era lo opuesto: fábricas
obsoletas, baja productividad y, sobretodo,
rentas mucho más bajas.
Todo esto, por no hablar de que los dos países
tenían sistemas políticos antagónicos.
Es decir, una situación parecida a la de
las dos Coreas aunque, en el caso alemán,
las diferencias eran menos extremas.
Como os podéis imaginar, si quieres que un
país pueden funcionar, tienes que armonizar
esta tipo de diferencias.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué hicieron los alemanes?
Pues básicamente, Alemania Occidental exportó
todas sus leyes, regulaciones y sistema fiscal
a la Alemania Oriental.
A cambio, el Oeste se encargó de pagar todos
los gastos del Este.
Eso significa que, de la noche a la mañana,
los impuestos de los ciudadanos occidentales
servían para pagar todas las carreteras,
ferrocarriles y calles que usaban los alemanes
orientales.
En principio, suena bastante lógico ¿No
os parece?
Es decir, si un país muy rico se junta con
otro muy pobre, tiene sentido que el uno ayude
al otro a recuperarse.
Pero, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
la economía es mucho más complicada y, a
veces, dar dinero no es suficiente.
Por muchas ayudas económicas, esta reunificación
supuso el colapso absoluto de la economía
de Alemania del Este.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué?
Pensadlo bien, de repente, Alemania era un
único mercado.
Y era un mercado donde las empresas del Oeste
eran mucho más competitivas que las del Este.
Por ejemplo, en la Alemania comunista tenían
una marca de automóviles, los famosos TRABANT.
Comparados con un BMW o un Audi, los Trabant
eran un juguete.
Así que la demanda de estos coches cayó
en picado.
Los Alemanes del Este abandonan sus Trabants
en Praga.
Así que imaginad la situación: trabajas
en la fábrica de Trabant y la empresa cierra
porque nadie compra sus coches.
Después, vas al supermercado y resulta que
todos los productos que compras están hechos
en el Oeste, que para algo tienen las mejores
fábricas.
Y que todo es mucho más caro porque… ¡Sorpresa!
De repente vives en un país rico donde los
precios son altos.
¡Pero eso no es todo!
Imaginad, por ejemplo, que sois un jubilado
de Alemania del Este.
Vuestra pensión estaba calculada en base
a los precios de la época comunista.
Pero, de repente, estamos en 1990 y cuando
vas al supermercado, el pan cuesta lo mismo
que en la Alemania del Oeste.
En otras palabras, es tres veces más caro
¿Entendéis lo que quiero decir?
La gente joven podía emigrar o buscar un
trabajo mejor ¿Pero qué puede hacer un abuelo
que se acaba de jubilar?
Pero la auténtica guinda del pastel era el
cambio de divisas.
Las dos Alemanias tenían 2 divisas distintas,
con distintos valores.
Así que los ministros de finanzas de ambos
países se juntaron en una sala y decidieron
fijar una tasa de cambio de 1 a 1.
Por supuesto, esto funcionaba muy bien en
la teoría.
Pero nadie en el mercado real te daba 1 marco
occidental a cambio de 1 marco oriental.
Por ejemplo, la mayor parte de los bancos
te pedían 2 marcos orientales a cambio de
1 marco occidental.
Y en el mercado negro, la tasa de cambio podía
llegar hasta los 12 marcos orientales por
un marco occidental.
En otras palabras, que el dinero que tenían
ahorrado los alemanes orientales, de la noche
a la mañana, valía mucho menos.
Con esta situación ¿Qué creéis que hizo
el Gobierno alemán para resolver esta situación?
La respuesta es subvenciones, subvenciones
y más subvenciones.
De repente, los contribuyentes del Oeste no
sólo pagaban infraestructuras sino también
la salud, la educación y muchos otros gastos
de sus vecinos del Este.
Para que os hagáis una idea, hablamos de
más de 70.000 millones de dólares TODOS
LOS AÑOS desde 1990.
Eso es algo así a organizar 4 juegos olímpicos
al año.
Y la pregunta es… después de 30 años ¿Podemos
decir que ha terminado el proceso de reunificación?
¿Podemos decir que Alemania es, al fin, un
país igualitario?
Pues… la respuesta es sí y, a la vez, no.
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver!
JUNTOS PERO NO REVUELTOS
Según un estudio, muchos alemanes dicen que
nunca se casarían con alguien de la “otra”
Alemania.
Tres cuartas partes de la población piensa
que todavía hay diferentes mentalidades entre
el Este y el Oeste.
Y el 10% de los alemanes orientales nunca
ha puesto un pie en la otra parte del país.
Y en lo que respecta a la economía, también
hay diferencias.
Si os fijáis en la gráfica, veréis que,
durante los primeros años de la reunificación,
la renta per cápita del Este era de unos
9.400 € mientras que, en el Oeste, era de
22.000 €. Hoy en día, las diferencias son
de 27.000 frente a 41.000 euros.
Sí, las diferencias son más suaves… pero
habría que ser muy tonto para decir que no
hay diferencias.
Y, por supuesto, están las diferencias culturales.
Según una investigación de la Universdad
de JACOB, en Bremen, los alemanes del Este
son los menos tolerantes con las minorías
y con los derechos LGTB.
¡Pero no solo hablamos de estudios!
Fijaros en las últimas elecciones.
Los votantes del Oeste votan, generalmente,
a partidos moderados como los Demócratas
Cristianos, que es el partido de Angela Merkel,
o los Socialdemócratas.
En el Este, sin embargo, es donde consiguen
votos los partidos más radicales: desde Alternativa
por Alemania, que es de extrema derecha, hasta
Die Linke, que es de extrema izquierda.
Y esto podría ser un problema porque podría
llegar el momento en el que los Alemanes del
Este, con sus votos, terminaran cambiando
las políticas que afectan al país entero.
Volviendo al ejemplo de las dos Coreas, imaginad
qué ocurriría si los Norcoreanos votaran
a partidos comunistas.
Y que, de repente, un líder como Kim-Jong-un
terminara tomando decisiones que afectaran
también a los surcoreanos.
Desde luego, esto podría ser un problema.
En definitiva, que hay muchas cosas buenas
que tendríamos que resaltar sobre la reunificación
Alemana.
A fin de cuentas, si seguís VisualPolitik
desde hace tiempo, no os va a sorprender si
os digo que Alemania es un país modélico
en muchas cosas.
Pero, como siempre decimos, no todo es tan
bonito.
Y si hubiera una reunificación de las dos
Coreas, hay muchos riesgos que tendríamos
que tener en cuenta.
Pero ahora, turno para vosotros ¿Creéis
que los Alemanes del Este, con una mentalidad
más radical que los del Oeste, podrían terminar
cambiando radicalmente el debate político
en Alemania?
¿Creéis que la reunificación alemana, pese
a todos sus problemas, podría ser un modelo
para la península Coreana?
Podéis dejarnos vuestras respuestas en los
comentarios.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas, y que el jueves
de esta semana hablaremos, por fin, de CATALUÑA,
así que suscribíos a VisualPolitik para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y compartidlo con vuestros amigos.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto!